[Musique]
caroline jamar la police tu sais bien à
vous à ma bourse
j'adore les
alors voyons voir ce qu'ils m'ont des
robes et mais il manque le portefeuille
bien sûr jean liquide ma montre
évidemment à ils ont laissé ses papiers
c'est gentil merci mon god ce que vous
regardez ça c'est cérumen ruben voilà
lorsque je me disais que j'avais déjà vu
ce thème vous avez l'air vous y
connaître en normal et pas que mais
c'est un peu mieux nolwenn a crime et de
partage
il faut du calme en tueur c'est quoi ce
bordel
on a tous voila connard tu as failli me
tuer ma femme tuée mais j'ai pas fais il
a dit que j'appelle à bas coûts ma
réponse elle a craqué la mise en plis ou
quoi la caisse à toi tu as un problème
c'est à une tête de gland temps vie te
prendre une branlée
faut vous calmer à les consanguins
l'attend au tournant
j'arrive à être des sons comme un soir
je vais trois pas de moi non loin d'un
crime et de plus chaud quoi at enfin
j'ai gagné c'est très positif
courez voir et il ya le moindre truc tu
aussi flou ok je veux siffler je peux
pas te parler s'occuper je travaille au
doigt groupe the supremes allait
s'ouvrir
amy tu vas confia le char charge
[Musique]
mc il a bousculé alors je suis là par
hasard couillon la teinte est rassuré
parce que sinon je te remets mexicaine
du coin pour qu'il transfère à manta
cochet